as we continue to wait patiently for the
return of our favorite show Stargate
we're going to do a series looking at
what we have got starting with some of
the sg1 ships that we know and love
first in line obviously the Prometheus
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
move your Channel
[Music]
if O'Neill had had his way this ship
would have been called the Enterprise
it's just one of those brilliant little
equips from O'Neill that we came to love
that's actually one of my favorite like
really favorite scenes if I had to pick
like five of my favorite scenes from
Stargate of all time
that scene would definitely be up there
when he had just a whole bit with Sam
but anyway for it they didn't approve
the mission oh no they did that once
they knew the stakes and the whole fate
of the universe stuff both president and
Hammond realized we had no choice he
sends good luck godspeed and all those
things he says when he thinks we're
gonna die
so what didn't I go for the name I
suggested for the ship yeah yeah sir
we can't call it the Enterprise why not
the code name for the project is
Prometheus what's wrong with that it's a
Greek tragedy who wants that
okay the x-303 it is then the Prometheus
dwarf all of the other Towery vessels up
to that point the f301 and the f302 the
x303 uh didn't have the best start to
its career It Got Hijacked immediately I
mean literally on the first time it got
out of dry dock straight away stolen so
joining us on the tour
I guess a couple billion dollars doesn't
buy what it used to
you'd be surprised this is Prometheus
otherwise known as the x-303
[Music]
[Music]
but it went on to have three amazing
years within this Target Universe even
though it was horribly undergunned
against almost everything it came up
against the Towery crew took the
Prometheus into battle repeatedly she
was 95 meters long 80 meters wide and
was capable of a hundred and ten
thousand miles an hour at sublight she
was powered by on a quadrary actor and
initially only had a Towery hyperdrive
even though it was quickly upgraded with
an Asgard hyperdrive Shields and sensors
as I say she was massively undergunned
considering some of the ships she went
toe-to-toe with she had 24 railguns 12
VLS missile tubes which is just a
standard missile system that we have
aboard Cruisers and battleships here on
Earth
VLS stands for vertical launch system
even though it did have an aqua tipped
nuclear missiles as well which did give
it a bit of a punch
compared to an atat or any other vessel
really it came up against it was
massively under good oh by the way if
you do like the content please consider
hitting the join button and becoming a
fully fledged side tracker you can also
go to sidestrek.com and pick marvelous
merchandise all of these little things
really help the channel also if you're
new to the channel like subscribe hit
that Bell notification and share the
video wherever the hell you want she did
carry 8 f302 interceptors she was
launched in 2002.
she was involved in some really
instrumental battles within that three
years that she existed before being
destroyed for example O'Neil took her
deep into replicator space and triggered
the time dilation trap for the asgards
don't know I said crap quite like that
but yeah well it's done there she was
also instrumental in defending Earth
during the Antarctica base when Anubis
came that close to invading us and
wiping us out thankfully we got to the
chair in Antarctica and all those little
yellow Squiddy things came up and
destroyed his Fleet
[Music]
foreign
cost
Prometheus
[Music]
emergency Trust
human attack vessel approaches
destroy it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the hell was that but if it wasn't for
the Prometheus he might have succeeded
the reason why I love the Prometheus was
because its design was just really like
down to earth it looked like something
we could actually build
it obviously had very limited technology
but that was Again The Genius of
Stargate they started with the x301 and
then the f302 but then the logical
progression was a larger battle cruiser
she wasn't too big she wasn't very well
armed the refit the Asgard did made her
defendable she had amazing Shields
obviously but I I love that as well that
the Asgard were willing to give us
technology but they didn't want to go
too far and they weren't willing to give
us weapons at that point they just
didn't trust us and well look at our
history they were right not to the
Prometheus was the only vessel ever
built of her class when the BC 304 was
then built from the Daedalus she
outclassed the Prometheus in almost
every way
[Music]
foreign
ties I was genuinely quite upset it
actually did get to me a little bit
so the Prometheus went into the tagless
system and went up against that or I
satellite
that they completely underestimated the
power of that satellite obviously
because it was constructed by a planet
that was behind us technologically they
completely underestimated the aura the
the effect for this whole scene are
amazing when that second blast cuts
through the spine of the Prometheus it's
a brilliant shot but God damn it upset
me it was like losing the Enterprise it
was like losing a vessel that you know
you really fallen in love with now don't
get me wrong the Bayless is a brilliant
ship as well and I'm going to be doing a
video on that next but at the end of the
day your first love always has a
slightly special place in your heart and
the Prometheus was my first Stargate
love
so guys get into the comments tell me
exactly what you think does the
Prometheus do it for you as much as it
does it for me get in the comments and
tell me exactly what you think if you
are new to the Channel please don't
forget to like subscribe hit that Bell
notification and if you enjoy the
content please show that love by hitting
the join button as always guys please
stay safe and I'll see you next time